ocelots are solitary animals they don't
spend much time hanging out but they do
leave scented messages for each other at
ocelot latrines researchers used a dog
to find four of these message boards in
Costa Rica camera traps at these
locations captured 16 ocelots paying 63
visits in six months the ocelots didn't
use the latrines daily but stopped by
occasionally to check messages and leave
their own marking territory is one use
for these signals but the latrines also
help coordinate meetups for males and
females
ocelots weren't the only ones checking
these messages 13 other species were
captured on camera kawatte EES came by
in big groups
Tyra's a type of weasel visited the
latrines even more than ocelots
and rodents opossums armadillos all
kinds of animals were also spotted
researchers don't know why Ocelot
latrines are such a popular spot for so
many different species but now that they
do they can monitor them or tracking
these elusive species keeping track of
biodiversity and checking in on the
impact of humans on these ecosystems
you